welcome to the center for international
news I'm David Packard political science
and I'm director of the institutions of
social and policy studies the center's
director in Shapiro asked me to fill in
for him today as he's teaching a class
and were delighted I'm personally
delighted to introduce David and we're
delighted to welcome Tim May you first
started and final act as this year's
Henry L Stimson lecturer and David
really is one of those colleges it needs
no introduction especially since so many
of you were probably and the previous
lectures but i'll just give it a sense
of his achievements with a list of
titles sterile Serling professor
emeritus fellow of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences member of the
American Philosophical society and the
National Academy of Sciences and even
more relevant titles Congress the
electoral connection divided you govern
America's Congress electoral realignment
parties and policies partisan balance
and we will soon be adding to this
prestigious list the imprint of Congress
to come out with Yale University Press
now if you've attended the previous two
lectures you've already learned about
how to think about Congress's imprint
and the history and it's time now for an
assessment of the title of today's
lecture and speaking of titles I should
say that this is funded by an anonymous
donor in honor of Henry L Stimson yelled
College 1889 an attorney and statesman
whose government service culminated with
his tenure as Secretary of War during
world war two and under more personal
note I wanted to say that it was my
dissertation advisor and my mentor is a
transited from student to faculty
colleague and he was my human Google
whenever I had a question that I
couldn't answer without without him so
and those were a lot of questions so I'm
grateful for all these roles as well as
for David's donation of his entire and
extensive pope collection to the
institution for Social Policy Studies
library which means that i guess that i
can now aspire to be
Google as well so I'm very pleased to
introduce professor database welcome
back or welcome a fresh as they reaching
it back there okay the mic is ok if
you're a fresh you'll never know how to
think about it or about the history but
you let you can get an assessment
they'll we are anyway welcome back and
and and and welcome afresh they are not
a nutshell recapitulation let's see now
what do i press for us i press some let
me put these up for us I've been
examining 13 transnational impulses I
call them that the USA has participated
in since 1787 with a particular rifle
Congress's imprint put in transnational
context and visa fee the presidency in
these instances and here they are again
the 13 no I last time I reached number
11 I stack it through a number 11 and I
said it was leaving up a 12-member 13
I'll do that this time and then I want
to do that so today actually has four
segments it adds a number 12 for merit
and is number 13 from here there's a
brief pause and then they have a couple
of interpretive arguments to make about
the whole business and then we'll stop
or rather rather will have question and
answer a Jacob will take over again the
interpretive exit exercises the third
and the fourth segment today they draw
for many of these instances though not
all of them as I said last time I'm not
trying to exhaust all of them by getting
into the interpretation and please save
your questions and answers to the end or
comments to the end we have to trot
right along as it happens given they
given the AA and win anyway we have a
half an hour for Q&A so we're going to
try now that the 12th of these actually
the top of the 13 are severed water over
there on their own table so to speak
because they still on the table that is
addressing climate change and in
controlling debt and deficit there there
and then not finished yet now generally
seeking I've avoided possible impulses
that are only part way through their
pulsation put it that way but climate
change worrying about it has been with
us a long time decades and so is
controlling debt and deficits isn't and
we get our teeth into I mean they're
they're open to analysis it seems to be
these impulses in the US us
participation and then Congress is
participation they're in now I'm address
a climate change I don't have to tell
you about the transnational context is
worrying about it because why
me about it across the world by that
yeah we have it you know there it is
there it is there it is something needs
to be done is out there as the as the is
the that's the coating the brief coating
of them of the of the impulse all right
the Americans and the Congress I've
tried to make an it for an Incan Ching
story for each of these 13 to draw out
an interesting story something
particular to Congress it's worth
relating I think in this case as climate
change the interesting story is this one
that that that Congress used to use to
set the standard for environmental
regulation not only for the USA before
the world back in the 1960s in the 1970s
it's really quite interesting I mean the
USA for one thing the Americans set a
world standard that's for at least a
year a standard for Europe in the USA in
the 60s and 70s this is before climate
change came along this is environmental
regulation before they were thinking
about global warming and climate change
at least very much but the Americans
were there and Congress took the lead in
doing that I'm going to there was a
little slide coming up here this is yeah
there's no one yes this is a one of the
greatest legislative vengers in American
history particular to a topic took place
in the 1960s in the 1970s having to do
in addressing the environment it's
really quite striking and there's no
doubt that Congress took the lead in it
I mean these are the years of of Johnson
Nixon and Ford Johnson's administration
is something they even that it was kind
of a co-equal to Senator muskie in the
Senate Johnson went out in 68 and
incomes Dixon it forward and most of the
action takes place in addiction the bulk
of the action takes place at a Nixon it
forward and the very important
instruments for the most part I did
Nixon now who did it well there is a
scholarship out there next to did it you
get some scholarship these days you'll
hear but it's really not true in dickson
sign things it's easy for presidents to
sign thing easy for presidents to sign
things but but actually next invito the
water quality control act they pass it
over is obito but for the most part an
overwhelmingly such as for the most
Congress served up these things in the
nineteen sixty 60 s and the 1970s under
these three flowers and it's nae became
law so it's obvious that the Congress
can act on madison vital regular marvel
regulation there it is and what the
story of it i think that there are
simple messages of blame and revit
that could be put out there and there
wasn't much opposition opposition of
these stories at the time and so they
filled up the statute blog but in the
Latin paws brief plasma the last quarter
century ago the as the focus has both to
quote climate change end quote then the
USA is becoming become something of a
laggard visa fee Europe something of a
lagger this is you know a fair amount of
scholarship that points that out Europe
has picked it up you're actually
following in American lead with what
they've been doing the last 25 30 years
or so that's it's fair to say at least
it's claimed by scholars Europe has has
surged ahead and the US says yeah well
it's fallen behind partly be not showing
up keeping up with a surge by the
Europeans so the quite what is the
recent pattern on this then the recent
pattern the last 25 or 30 years or so 25
years ago and make it that way made
presidents at least some presidents have
taken the lead on climate change the
Democratic president says Clinton and
Obama not the Republican presidents
least not very much but Clinton and
Obama yes they're out there tub
something now and then foreign climate
actually Obama quite strikingly lately
and Congress has become much more
reluctant that as we see now that
disparity between the branches and the
age of climate change Congress much more
reluctant and it's not just a party
thing we Congress has become a reluctant
for example in 1997 when Clinton was out
there trying to put trying to get the US
are trying to try to arrange the Kyoto
Protocol the Kyoto Protocol the Kyoto
Protocol the Senate preemptively voted
it down by dinah five to nothing that's
not even close in 1997 also the
Democrats in 2009 under Obama they tried
they often they puffed to put a cap and
trade bill o in the books but it didn't
work they couldn't get it through the
Senate you can take it up in the city
even though they do have live at large
majorities in both houses that's just
not just the Republicans though it's
finally the Republicans part of the
story now in recent times is that
climate change has mapped onto partisan
polarization with the Republicans being
of patiently more more resistant to both
the diagnosis than they proposed
remedies having to deal with a climate
change both those things both those
things now I would guess for one reason
for why they have the
one reason for the particular
congressional congressional reluctance
during this last patch of history is
this one that spent is the point of it
last time about about foreign policy
that Congress sent to be after 10 stone
insularity me Congress does back away
from international commitments
intrusions annexations invasions and so
on generally speaking they shy away and
the aikido palau climate change is an
international thing it's a it's an
international agreement kind of thing
it's very different from what was going
on in the 60s and the 70s and i think
from the looking at it from the outside
the Kyoto Protocol and problems got
Capitol Hill something like joining the
World Court had in the 1930s that is to
say president wanted the Congress backed
away from at least partly for insularity
reasons but there's also a partisan
split as I say the Republicans were
elected and I think they're a
generalization of either with that is
that for Republicans have been generally
speaking a more nationalist of the two
parties for century and a half it's not
a new thing that's more reluctant to get
mixed up in internationalism
international agreements and we think of
the world we think of the reciter ET we
could make a list and I think this is
another instance of that so we have both
Congress's general been taught
insularity and the Republicans general
bent toward nationalism backing up
what's now it's become the split between
what the president's are trying to do
and what Congress will agree to even so
all I haven't even said it's not clear
that the Americans are off standard that
is the usual pack of countries of rich
countries in the results of trying to
deal with climate change their studies
of this it was a 2014 which I give the
gist up here there was a study at the
oecd out of Brussels i think it was of
Environmental Policy stringency that's
been bought into it by the various
country 25 or 30 countries something
like that in the US is a little under
the main the median but not much many US
is of less clean put it that way then
Scandinavia the devlins Canada Japan but
it's it's less dirty by this standard
than Britain France Australia Italy and
Belgium I'm sure it's not that really
far away from from from the from the
from
the generic of international for fun
wish which may be a low bar often a
general performance is a low bar and we
have to think about that too but I'm
making this comparison there it is
that's that one now on to the to the
last impulse pause last impulse this is
controlling debt and deficit and there
the at we have another familiar
transnational context that's through
1973 it's roughly a quarter century
after world war two is this okay with a
mic back there still is the economies of
all these countries are booming we're
looking at high growth rates so the
government's got in the habit of
spending money during these times since
since nineteen twenty-three the
economies have slowed down the revenue
is slowed down but the spending hasn't
slowed down generally see i'd say
probably that's the gist of a diagnosis
of the difficulty that these various
countries have faced during the last 40
years or so and hence this long-term
pressure on debt deficit with a lot of
predictions of doom down street if
something is known about this now i want
it's clear the debt deficit not the only
concern of these countries and it
shouldn't be and we know that i mean
there are trade-offs year we know that
too nonetheless that deficit in the long
term not going bankrupt as a as its as
from this way it's a widespread concern
as an empirical better it's a widespread
concern for those who who cast forward
to think about 34 years or now and it's
not a surprise to you could read in the
newspaper now the american record we're
going to start with a comparison with
other countries right now this is a 2011
comparison and a good one what dog funny
i say you did this they're going to work
or put it this way yeah yeah there's a
study there it is a good study 2011 the
the US is right in the pack I in control
of that deficit of 2011 that is not
distinctive nowhere near any kind of a
outlier exceptionalism performance by
the USA compared with SE 25 or 30 other
country just one of the pack a freer of
debt and better condition by this
standard would be the spain netherlands
poland so what's the little Australian
deeper in debt or every one of the other
g six countries that run elections that
is that as japan italy france canada
germany as germany coming on somebody
asked last time we as germany is germany
and both of these roundups I've done in
the last ten minutes I guess generic not
exceptional you know it scored two again
for non American exceptionalism and
against gore tool for the idea that's
maybe a low bar after all I mean all
these countries may be bankrupt 40 years
from now that's true too but I'm trying
to make comparisons or measurements
across reality rather than across
aspiration actually a lot of politics
consists of persisting and aspiration
and sometimes you persist in aspiration
anything you've got to pay off sooner or
later that's them all right now actually
the again the US and actually into less
what is it 10 years now or eight years
eight years now since the Wall Street
Crash of 2008 compared with the other
countries the American performance on a
debt deficit question again that's
that's not the only one you want to look
at is is really quite impressive that is
the US has shown us system has shown
itself to be quite quite quite flexible
going over this since 2008 there are
some components of that in 2008 2009
which means very late Bush 43 and the
first two years of Obama with a
Democratic Congress where they put
through the big stimulus bill you
remember that the American a countess
sound a cyclical fiscal passage of 2008
2009 was exemplary among a set of peer
countries the one measure has it the the
biggest the biggest spur that in
consequence poor among 31 countries
another one what third place out at 31
countries something like that I mean the
US is off the charts and it's in its in
its assertive Keynesianism in 2008 2009
which is interesting but after that
after after that in 2011 12 and 13 and
after that actually after the Congress
turns Republican through the election
election of November 2010 they started
they went in the other direction and
since 2010 the bite that the Americans
have taken from debt deficit has been
huge 2.7 trillion bucks
in over the over three or four year
period they've done naturally through
the budget deal in 2011 ringing and the
sequester they call it at the sequester
of funds is pretty much held since then
are the the the fiscal cliff deal of
january first 2013 what these two big
enactments did bring were a combination
of spending cuts and tax hikes tax hikes
insisted on by obama and gotten and JT
grave 2013 that have added up to this
bike and it's really quite something so
you get into 2015 and a measure early
this year had it that the amount of the
budget this is not exactly debt but it's
ephesus the american national federal
deficit has now fallen below a 40-year
average which is interesting now that's
mostly due to the probably or at least a
great deal due to the uptick of the
economy but it also a great deal due to
the bite that they took out of it during
those times so it but over over the wall
over the 25 years or so or 50 years or
so probably the judgment would be that
the American American performance is
generic that is not a typical but pretty
good during the last eight years its own
now as the Congress Congress is placed
in this which I play a lot do a lot with
and they look ready to skip they just
don't want to be brave I want to be very
brief here do what is Congress isn't
what it's gone general what is
Congress's contribution to the handling
of debt deficit well for a couple of
points there is there is there is there
is no evidence or logic that the super
majoritarianism of Congress as
exemplified in the Senate filibuster
causes death deficit problems you can do
budgets with the reconciliation and they
routinely do that's a majority rule on
both sides there's no evidence that
divided party control of the government
as opposed to its opposite as anything
to do with performance so plus or minus
having to do with that deficit we could
run through the evidence and we do I
think you'd agree with you on that one
that having been said I think that over
a long period of time and this is a very
next question that's a tough question
about which this is something there's
some scholarship but not enough and it's
very difficult to address given at least
the problem of anticipated reactions
as the presidency in a Congress deal
with each other your fuss with each
other on money matters it's a difficult
one I would I think that it's a fair
guess that that the president is a
little more agile over in guarding the
FISC so to speak that it's guarding
against that deficit problems then is
Congress may be a little bit but but
it's a tough one and difficult to
address and generally speaking the the
the cumulative performance of the
presidency and the Congress who can
either compliment or oppose each other
but there has to be a resultant that
comes out of it as the as the aspect of
making the u.s. performance of generic
rather than rather than exceptional one
way or another in general all right not
as a pause that's number twelve in
number 13 now I want to draw out a
couple of interpretations that come from
many of the discussions of the 13
impulses as I said one of them has to
deal with the stability and legitimacy
of the American system and of Congress
within it the other has to do with the
messiness of congressional activity you
see maybe five or six or seven different
impulses flow into discussion of the
former and another five or six or seven
of the same ones will flow into a
discussion of the latter but I won't
bother to enumerate them as i go through
da stability and legitimacy the american
system let's see i'll put this one up
now I like here they I fear II backed up
by evidence that's a brought to us was
some years ago by Matt Matt Shughart and
Carrie I did I've gotta go to 1 i'm
going to be we ought to say but let me
preface that by saying that as i did in
lecture number one this presidential
separation of power systems can be
unstable can be unstable after all we
could make a list but the US system
leaving aside the Civil War has been
extraordinarily stable going back to
1787 I want to say that to again and
that means it's basic constitutional
institutions have been stable originally
unquestioned the nature of them the
persistence of them so for that matter
is the geographic composition of the USA
that is in some countries i've brought
Breton those problems Spain has problems
canada is vociferous the USA well it had
the 1860s of the Civil War but the last
century or so there's no they don't they
only talk we hear secession is from I
guess what a some some folks out in
Hawaii but other than that aside there
is not much going on on that front now
has Congress contributed to the
stability and legitimacy of the American
system thus discussed and I think the
answer is yes now there they I want to
break up again Matt shughart and John
Kerry there are they got this
comparative politics which I'm sure some
of you are familiar with than I am which
has it that it's about presidential and
parliamentary systems and their argument
is that one of their arguments is that
presidential systems that have
legislators that are constitutionally
powerful a particularly good for system
particularly contributed to system
civility and legitimacy that I said the
US as it happens across a whole bunch of
presidential systems does have a
constitutionally well empowered
legislature matching it maybe cost the
rico and the oddities office author
otherwise after well after they got to
look for a while to find Congress's that
are as powerful constitutionally visibly
presidents as is the US Congress needs
to be the US president which is
interesting now why might it be true
that such systems with strong
legislators contribute to to system
legitimacy well the argument of our
garden carry is that legislators by
nature can be pretty good they aren't
always but they can be pretty good at
accommodating disagreement across
heterogeneous populations pretty good at
accommodating disagreements across
heterogeneous populations after all you
have 530 folks on Capitol Hill rather
than just one person is in the White
House and they're going to be different
they're going to be taste it's going to
be a variety of tastes they're not least
a legislature can weigh and accommodate
a variety of odor tastes and intensities
intensity has come in I said probably
one of the very important jobs of
legislators is to accommodate
differentials and intensity that is some
people out then the electron wants
something a lot and the rest of the
people out there to really don't care
very much I mean an instance would be
that Nevada Tecna
we don't dump nuclear waste into Nevada
why is that because the divider senators
say we can't do it the other ninety
eight senators are probably vote for it
but the two are to the divided the
Senators get off in their high or
sinister than none the stop being said
with Harry Reid out of the picture maybe
we will be able to adopt a new ways of
the vitamin nobody knows that's a
perfect instance of accommodation of
intensities it will come about through
explicit or implicit accommodation of La
Croix exporter explicit or implicit log
rolling in a legislature which can be
allowed by the rules but where are the
rules come from the rules are renton are
designed at least to some degree to
accommodate implicit or explicit black
rolling in a legislature all that is
theory now what other reasons for Kerry
and Shughart is that legislators can be
contributed stability of the system is
that they can stare down or defeat
rambunctious or sectarian presidents
rambunctious or sectarian presidents
after all presidents only one person
maybe got there by a light no majority
vote is kind of crazy maybe we could all
give instances of red boxers presidents
and sectarian presidents whereas with
535 folks on Capitol Hill it's more
difficult to be add up to either too
rambunctious sisters or 40 or sectarian
this but they try sometimes to be sure
that's true but even so on average
that'll be the case now this sub carey
and sugar it sound like the USA and i'd
like to develop it using my impulses
weaving some stuff from them into one
large particular history and then into a
more general history and argument this
is still under the rubric of stability
and legitimacy of the system we're not
getting to the last the fourth of the
things yet yes the general the the the
the large particular history is this one
and it is a tragic history it involves
race and racism you know a lot of
history doesn't look very good they say
madness and crimes and follies that's
what history amount still well the until
lately though recently the US has been
some people say is but recently it
certainly has been a white man's country
not even a white person's just but we
could leave it here white
advanced country so recently it's um and
and it's it's congress until recently
and it occurring the it helping along
the legitimacy of the system has
encouraged sense of legitimacy among
whites not among blacks but it's gone
out of its way to accommodate the
variety of tastes in the white public
for north and south which isn't easy has
been easy over American history
generally speaking what a legislature do
is to respond to voters and if people
don't vote they don't count answer most
of American history the black population
is either not protocol or voted in small
numbers until actually the last five
decades so that's been the case again if
you don't vote you don't count let me
run through the oh let me run through
the run through the history of this it's
it's it's a complicated history it
involves Congress it involves race and
it involves legitimizing among the
whites from beginning to end all right
we're going to keep that in the air I
mean the first sector of history and we
all learned this when we were 13 or
before that even it sought through the
Civil War the story of Congress over and
over again that we read about is that
they arrange these big deal compromises
does Missouri Compromise the compromise
of 1850 those are the big ones are some
other ones which which were efforts
after all to keep the rather loosely
arranged Union anyway stitched together
by accommodating the views of the
northern whites and the southern whites
basically not if they're it's other
throats a person to present loggerheads
all the time but but there it is if that
was it that was it at the price of
preserving slavery of the south after
all that was written into these deals 18
nobody was crying at the rough slavery
in the south and the missouri compromise
and the compromise of 1850 this right up
through the winter of eighteen sixty
sixty one where the country was falling
apart as a civil war was coming in like
it's taking over the presidency it was
still the instinct of Congress to do
that again has given its way concrete
given it certainly
Congress is trying in the winter of
eighteen sixty sixty one to arrange
another compromise like the compromise
of 1850 that would keep the country
together at the expense of southern boys
of keeping slavery that was that they're
good they may have succeeded given their
own given their own head but that came
Lincoln in the Republicans and then that
went off the agenda as a likelihood as a
1861 that that was the before the Civil
War go and as reconstruction
reconstruction of the south which is
pretty tough for a while lasts for a
brief span after the world war after the
Civil War 18 65 66 baby through or
through 18 70 or 71 and it's a pretty
strong form and through most of that an
interesting background facts of that is
that the the white South was not
represented on Capitol Hill during those
years for several years there there was
a northern country in Congress for
several years the median voter was
somebody probably in Pennsylvania rather
than somebody in Kentucky there 1867 or
1872 or so that was a background during
which reconstruction policies to which
should be sure flowed directly out of
the war and the passions therefrom came
out came out of that was it but bring
the southern states back into the
Indiana where are we the the southern
states come back and came back into the
Union and the suffrage among southern
african americans which is conferred in
the in the late 1860s and 1870s
gradually frittered away so that by 1900
or 1905 that's very little left of it at
the southern say it's not only yeah we
have to realize that the South has
always been dominantly white mean
it'sit's else is about to was probably
then something like two-thirds white so
you hold elections in the cells and one
person one vote and you know there's
going to be a lot of Dixie set of it
it's going to result from the returns
regardless of whether there's a
african-american suffrage but not all
that's going so what happened was that
between the 1870 between the mid-1870s
and the 1960s it's a long time as almost
a century the place of the place the
Congress had a very important place in
legitimizing and reala jit amaizing the
country among whites of the two sections
I mean it
country had to be stitched back together
again it was thought after all they've
killed each other eight hundred thousand
casualties during in civil war which is
not nothing and they what we do get is a
long history of accommodating
cross-regional views and what that means
cross it's in it does it is any symmetry
of intensity during those many decades
the 18th this is in all of American
history a long-lasting asymmetry of
intensities on Capitol Hill is best it's
best exhibited in the North versus South
northern size versus what southern
northern wise throwing presents I said
during these many decades in the
southern southern whites with very
intense on keeping this the racial caste
system together down there northern
whites were probably so be they didn't
like the idea but we're not willing to
go to the wall against it or pretty
tough it on things and so in the Senate
in a legislative body that accommodates
a cemetery intensities then there was
the process was a natural for for run an
accommodation across the sections and
the the the process for executing that a
combination during the from 1890 through
1968 was this regression alia samba
school rough with it the Senate
filibuster the Senate filibuster the
Senate filibuster during 1917 through
1970s so I took it took two-thirds of
the Senate to shut it down now it takes
three fifths of the Senate to shut down
a filibuster and during that time the
house the House of Representatives
sometimes send up pass and send up civil
rights bills having to at least with
with the franchise in the south and to
do with anti-lynching in the south and
the Senate batted them down there's
nothing came out of the Senate nothing
came out of the Senate and the civil
rights front door he knows there ain't
got several generations I want to make
this particular point that the
filibuster door he knows during those
times it's very much a a civil rights
filibuster that is the the story of the
filibuster we grew up with this and
maybe we've gone away from it now since
our experience of the filibuster
recently is somewhat different once a
was a civil rights story the again it
was a perfect fit the process for for an
execution in a symmetrical
densities that is the southerners that
gap and say we're going to say here all
night we're just not going to give up
unless you folks agree lets you folks
cave in and the northerners would cave
in they say something else is more
important than civil rights we've got to
get to the economy who cares about civil
rights even the progressive senators
would say in the 1930s for example and
they move away from civil rights on the
Senate floor and the the filibuster as a
process was was very craftily developed
and honed by southern sedatives to be to
enter into the very fine form it took
when some of us were young in the 1950s
in the 1960s said it's a very clear
device for executing civil rights bills
that might come over from the house by
the way the the until that until the
1980s or so that is Reagan territory
it's just plain not true that it took
two thirds or three trips or whatever to
legislate in the Senate I'm mostly it
just didn't it did on civil rights
during those times but it's a conceit of
our time to have this arrangement
wherein 60 votes over there can kill
almost anything are 41 votes 41 senators
can kill almost anything that's the
process it's existed with us now since
the mid 80 and we fall into an easy
assumption that it's always been the
case for forty-one percent of the Senate
to stop almost anything it's simply not
true through most of American history
right up through the through the through
the through through the 1970s if a
majority party really wanted something
they could get it by majority vote on
the Senate floor as well as the House
floor maybe not in the last five days of
a session when things get clogged up but
generally speaking that was true now
it's a divot some or a different
question to take to carry a little more
on this a Senate and a filibuster during
that 75 years or whatever it is ugly you
know the use of this process it's a
summer question whether it's a somewhat
question a different question how much
they said it at its processes were a
cause of the preservation or the
non-interference off put it that way or
the solidification of the southern
racial caste system after
construction it's somewhat different and
as I think it's easy to go to go
overboard and and make up a
counterfactual that oh well if only the
Senate didn't have the filibuster and
voted for some of these things than the
South would have vastly changed in the
1890s and I t tends in nineteen twenties
I doubt it I mean essentially the bottom
line on the south from the 1860's
through the 1950s was that in Ottawa to
make a serious dent into the into the
racial hierarchy down there it took the
northern military in the northern
military where's the 1860s the late
1860's early eighteen seventy then went
away and to dictate and to desegregate
the schools in Little Rock in 1957 it
was again federally induced I don't know
what maybe militia but anyway somebody
sent there by Eisenhower and for a
little rock in 1957 so I don't want but
at least the Senate during those times
was the part of the cause probably of
the preservation of the of the southern
racial caste system and at least it was
the the location for the for the
procedural execution procedural carry
out of policies are non carry out of
policies which led to the effect of not
intruding or helped to lead to the
effect of not intruding into the
southern racial caste system all right
now so Congress as a as I briefly you
know this is it briefly mentioned when
the civil rights revolution did come
along in the 1950s and 60s the lead on
it came from the courts and from the
presidency no question about that the
lead out there say we've got to do this
the core statement got to do that I mean
after world war two Sherman was pretty
quick out of the box with important
speeches on the civil rights front
Eisenhower Kennedy Johnson sent up civil
rights bills that's your history of
those debts the presidencies history the
agencies are very important and config
of affirmative action policies under
Johnson another Nixon the late sixties
early seventies that's true also but
Congress sudden and the mid-60s Congress
did participate and the enactment of the
great civil rights enactments
in Civil Rights Act of 1964 and the
Voting Rights Act of 1965 these are the
big ones these are the big ones both
went through with over two-thirds of
people voting for him and both the house
in the Senate both went through with big
majorities of both Republicans and
Democrats voting for them in both the
House and the Senate and these
instruments that Congress passed were
very important legitimizing events for
the success of the civil rights
revolution and one thing around the
books the southern the sudden as they
folded they folded it would see once
these are not too though I think what
happened as a background was by the
mid-1960s given changes in sentiment and
public opinion of the country the
intensities of the two sections among
whites this northern white Southern
whites the difference in intensities on
these racial matters equilibrated and as
it was his southern intensity winter way
northern intensity rose on a pro civil
rights side in the 50s and 60s we get an
equilibration equilibration more or less
in the mid 60s and your filibuster
process can't be executed anymore in the
Senate and it wasn't successfully
executed 64 and 65 in the late 60s and
after 64 and 65 pretty quickly after
that late sixties the civil rights
filibuster came to an end we've had a
lot of Scylla Buster's since then but
since then I can't remember any so of us
the holding on civil rights bill and
it's just playing out the case at the
senate since the late 60s been has been
more hostile to civil rights enterprises
that has the presidency the house on
average is just not true i close here
with a quote the section this is from
Senator Fritz Hollings of South Carolina
in 1970 didn't make the Sun a flawed
this is a statement from the cloakroom
the somebody wrote down and gave to Gary
or field into a book don't ask me to go
out there at filibuster I'm not going
back to mine stain and explain a
filibuster against the black voters this
is the south carolina democratic state
mamaya stone and history of South
Carolina that a Democratic senator from
South Carolina would make it it's a do
it's a new listen to order yes
I work now the bat that exemplification
of legitimizing among mites is not
attractive but the general case of
legitimizing leaving it out I think over
American history is is more attractive
the general case across 225 years is
that Congress often is pretty good at
accommodating a heterogeneity of tastes
and intensities and doing that is the
contribution probably to system
legitimacy no surprise there that's what
legislators do often and and I want to
give you a recitation of some instance
this here just make it yeah yes there
sometimes Congress is pretty good at
crafting enactments that that that have
a that have a with majorities that have
a certain capacious pneus on Capitol
Hill is you gotta you're going to put
something on the books and hope that
it'll stick it makes sense to go out of
your way to accommodate a variety of
tastes across the country it's an
extremely heterogeneous country notice
heterogeneous as some but you put
together South Carolina with Vermont and
it's always been at least on that
dimension very heterogeneous put
together idaho in rhode island we could
be and I would make a list they've here
are some here some instances of this I
mean I talking here about about Congress
of putting together instruments measures
that with a quite capacious majorities
enactment majorities are right and I
mean in case we'd hear will be that to
do this is to help make the measures
themselves stick over time and also
probably to contribute to the legitimacy
the assistant period through through a
succession over time of important moves
that do stick that become part of the
history of the country there so I think
especially nice for if you're
creating an important instances sick is
to get majorities of both congressional
parties parties on board and passing
something that is majorities on board
final passage final passage is very
important and enacting something and
some instances of this is social
security act in 1935 went through
they're not ready Republicans in
Congress in 1935 nhd be said but of
those who were there most of them in the
house and the senate voted to pass the
thing that's it of course both Democrats
and that's important if that happens
it's very difficult for the opposition
the opposition party the party who
wasn't primarily at the switch on it to
go out and grouse about it or to try to
destabilize or sabotage whatever was put
on the books they have to explain after
all of they've voted for the damn thing
better care in 1965 at least in the
house not in the Senate I think a
plurality of Republicans voted against
it but on the house side the bulk of
Democrats and most Republicans in the
House voted to enact Medicare this is a
very important and illuminating an
interesting event the way they did this
in the house the the congress i think in
trying to get something on the books and
make it stick at its best that is well
below what's the head of the Ways and
Means give me at that time and he went
out of his way to took effect this isn't
me written about by him by Jacob and
also by Peter Swensons it would affect a
version of the instrument which which
put an important component that had been
fostered by the Republican ranking
member of the house and waste committee
John Burns the Democrats probably could
have gone they probably could have got
what they wanted anyway by majority vote
just shouting down the Republicans but
it was good politics good politics be
good for the lasting stability of the
thing to undo what the hills and Johnson
agreed to Johnson the presidency agreed
to then on Medicare addenda a civil
rights acts of 64 and 65 that I
mentioned after those were on the books
with those two-thirds majorities
overcoming filibusters the southern
opposition to at least on these fronts
as public accommodations
and and voting rights folded and just
went away down there the issue dropped
out of southern politics after that
after them alright another another kind
of pattern is this switch probably it's
important enactment coalition's by an
enactment coalition I mean they list the
roll call photo voted for firewood for
final passage on something in the house
in the Senate with at least some
non-trivial cross-party composition not
trivial was that mean I don't know what
it means more than two or three that
isn't a 20 or something over and I had
30 in the house or 15 or 20 in the
Senate enough so that whatever was done
can generally are reasonably generally
to be claimed to a Fed profs party
support and when a party loses twenty
percent of its members to the ruling
party the minority party loses twenty
percent of its members on something like
this to the ruling part is a party on
top is somewhat difficult for the
minority party to claim that whoever
voted fad thing is an idiot because some
of the wrong people did so again as good
politics to operate this way this way to
get the at least that degree of
prosperity acquiescence in doing
something big and well among the the
impulses I talked about many of the
Business Regulation Bulls of eight in
the 1880s and on would exemplify this
the shift of progressive taxation and
the first two decades of the 20th
century yes the the the the big shift
upward that I talked about 1916 came
from Democrats with some support of
progressive Republicans but the
Democrats probably woulda did that are
alone in the house but the 16th
amendment income tax amendment to the
Constitution came out of Republican
Congress in 1909 now under pressure for
progressives but nonetheless it came out
with the acquiescence of president
William Howard Taft and as to that
probably on the likelihood that the
Republic who could say that being in
favor of the state was idiotic was
reduced by the fact of tacit Taft
acquiescence and and not just that that
that they came out of a Republican
Congress the infrastructure moves of the
1950s that went into some detail on that
highway program and the rest the
environmental reforms in the six
60s and 70s these are the politics is
confusing the Democrats took the lead on
virtually everything on Capitol Hill on
these clean air clean water and the rest
that's true but there was a lot of
Republican support and a lot of them had
either Nixon's of fourth signature on
them which gave a a cross-party stamp
generally speaking to this on this bench
this legislative bingeing at that time
the neoliberal izing response i talked
about of the 1970s maybe the early 1980s
under early reagan what had a
cross-party stamp that is a of all
deregulating the railroads now the
airline deregulating the airlines a
member of Congress who was most out
front and on television in favoring that
was a Senator Edward Kennedy of
Massachusetts for example or even get
into 1981 with the reagan tax cuts most
members of most democrats in both the
House and the Senate on final passage
voted for the reagan tax cuts they
didn't like it but they voted for it
there at what the budget deals in 1981
under reagan 1985 under reagan 1990 on
the bush the father 1997 clinton
gingrich deal 2011-2013 deals between
the obama white house in the republican
house basically all these had to be
cross burning the tarp bailout of 2008
there we are another instance don't i
want to go back one where are we did I
make a mistake doing it I'm okay all
right prefixes John fixers these things
for me it's okay here are some another
pattern of cross-party ISM is mentions
that were enacted under formal divided
party control that is I haven't talked
about that specifically here this in
this last year paragraphs but the formal
divided party control what that means is
that one party has one of the three
elective institutions how Senate and
presidency the other party has the other
two there's no other possibility unless
is a tie in the Senate a 2 and 1 a 2 and
1 a 2 and 1 split the j trading at seven
96 for example then I talked about a
very important legislative instrument
I'm bringing the u.s. back end of the
British trading area came under divided
party control which is a vexed matter by
the way it's not entirely clear who had
formal party control of the house in
1796 but there's good writing about it
by John Hoadley the Interstate Commerce
Act which is the first great regulatory
instrument in 1887 enacted bios is at
that time there's a republican senate
and our democratic president cleveland
the norris-laguardia ACT one of the
important labor instruments signed by
over served up by his democratic house
in 1932 was public and senate a little
bit the Marshall Plan 1948 Republican
Congress Stroman interstate highway act
Democratic Congress Eisenhower Clean Air
Act Democratic Congress nixon reagan tax
cuts republican presidency and Senate
Democratic House on the books divided
party control all these yes the general
case I'm making here it's again it's a
more some more fragrant a more
attractive case I think you might not
like a lot of these that you probably
like some of these instruments you
probably like most of these measures
though not all of them but unbalanced
they have a more fragrant fragrant to
aspect to them and I sub nearly two
centuries of white supremacy on Capitol
Hill there which is so neat they'll take
the case I gave before of legitimizing
yes now to finish this off do I put this
down here yes I've been talking about
legislative action I think also i'm
going to hit this very briefly because
it doesn't come out of the impulses and
but still i think it's out there it's
difficultly going to finger on it's that
I think the congressional inaction
that's doing nothing as bread lock
deadlock so forth all those nouns and
adjectives I coughed up a couple of
times last last time can play into the
shoe guy Kerry argument also now
unquestionably Congress isn't very good
at in action you know I gave you a list
of those adjectives you know deadlock
and soph went dead look at democracy and
so what changed in Gregor burns the
broken branch and so on all that list
we've been hearing about that since
nineteen nineteen forty-five
it's all out there but i think if you
think its rooms that I think it through
it seldom thought through inaction also
can be for the system legitimizing I
mean it would be an insane society that
had the view the more laws the better
just for openers from insane society but
beyond that when when the society out
there and again it's a very it's very
heterogeneous society is polarized or
it's a dissonant it's a little different
from polarized dissident means you got
you know five or six different sounds
coming in here and where they're coming
from or something like that or
irresolute which means that people are
scratching their chins out there even
though what the pulse is bring in front
of us suggest that they've already made
up their minds there's an awful lot of
chin scratching that goes on after all
where the public is polarized or
dissonant or air resolute it is not
surprising at all that a representative
is representative institution will do
nothing will do nothing not at all
surprising not at all surprising there's
a sense in which it is their duty or at
least it's to do nothing in that
circumstance or at least you put that
out there as an opening premise and
anyway it seems to me if you think about
it you want to make some to put an
asterisk sonic and and then make up some
kinds of instances in which most of us
might agree that they should do
something anyway even if they are being
unrepresentative so to speak by going
beyond this conflict and dissonance and
ear resolution after all it is it's a
representative Republic but in some
senses it is a democracy rather than
just an outfit that that should enact
what people on the iPad pages they
should an ax after all I say Congress
since easily in doing nothing doing
nothing is often responding to the
public with the perfect dear it's the
matter of a resultant a rather a vector
of views or tastes or sounds coming up
into a resultant and a resultant
possibly for this result of doing
nothing finally this is the fourth unit
of today we're doing okay this is a
feely this is shorter than the third one
and the messiness I want to talk about
the messiness of congressional activity
and this essentially it jumps out of
many of the 13 impulses I've talked
about I mean the the inconstancy of
Congress's treatment of things as you go
all the time the incoherence as it talks
and puts things on the books the
particular ISM as it dulls out says that
or another thing cumulating it to
something you can't tell what it is all
those all those nouns are nouns are
recurrent as characterizations of what
goes on down there and some exhibits
I've run through these almost all of
these I talked about distributing the
land that came bit of possession of the
federal government between these 18
1780s and then 19 1860s and so deserting
the land I ran through that new this
ragged populism changed the rules bail
out the debtors legitimizes quarter do
this do this bailout the debtors make
them make them give them credit make
them pay but then all Ansel and unlike
the student loan program something like
that exhibit baywood might be old tariff
system the old tariff system of the 19th
and the first third of the 20th century
in its incarnation of at least they a
distributive Christmas tree as silver
gets gets this and the old people get
that and the iron people get that and
they put it together into a measure
that's that that's that's the only
reason they did the tariff but it's what
it's not the only explanation of how
they why they did it they are for this
one explanation the civil war veteran's
pension system I haven't talked about
that i just mentioned it but this at all
of American history I stumble down in a
very interesting text written in 1912 by
the latest member then latest important
member of The Addams Family not child
but Charles Francis Adams to something i
forgot more why the third or fourth or
something like that it was a progressive
reformer of that time and it's a
fascinating book
to get out of the library and almost
fell apart when I put it into my hands
it's a little booklet it's about the
civil war veteran's pension system which
is it written about anyway very nicely
by its out of scotch ball it's not this
is this man is different greatly with
what the schedule has to say but it is
it it's Exhibit C here it is a wonderful
exhibit of congressional messiness that
is pension system civil war pension
system Civil War veterans and then their
widows over over time the pension system
goes out for at least four decades
siding and I think in the 70s and here
are some of its features there are
thousands of special pension bills you
come in and you ask and bring a lawyer
and maybe they'll give you a pension
there are also a few omnibus measures as
adding to that in together very
important omnibus measures and in 1990
for example having to deal with those
pensions there is balance policy
sovereignty on Capitol Hill as
bureaucrats are not deciding these
things except at the desk when somebody
comes to pick up the check Congress is
deciding the policy who gets what in
principle there's a committee that
handed out particular eyes benefits
committee in the house it was a credit
credit claiming utopia for the members
as you can go back to the Iowa 3rd or
the or the messages of six and say I got
your pension or I voted for this class
of folks of whom you're one who all get
a pension there was state of the odd
interest group lobbying the Grand Army
of the Republic came along and set up
shop on Capitol Hill or near it there is
a logic of program expansion that's keep
increasing the whole thing year after
year after year till becomes quite
universalistic welfare program by the
1890s and there's a strong tendency also
to bipartisan universalism that is at
least involving northern veterans as
southern Confederate Army veteran did
get pensions from DC but northern
veterans both black and white or their
widows did so among those who we want to
put northern Democrats with Republicans
and there's a very strong tendency sewed
bipartisanship and the conducting of
this politics it's a fascinating
politics during these many decades and
there it is that's Exhibit D Exhibit D
which I talked about before would be the
veterans bonuses
thing between the wars 1920's 1930's the
exhibit a might be the treatment of by
congress of the silver interests of
silver industry between the 1870s the
1930s another would be over a century
and a half or so anyway or century and a
quarter or so anyway tax breaks has
ground out by capitol hill committees
that is tax break for this registry or
something like they heard one drop tax
credit which is a tax break after all
for a class of the population a lot of
the tax code is joel apolinar was saying
last time consists of stuff put in there
that exempts some various classes of
people from bank taxes of certain kinds
medicaid expansion in the nineteen
recent decades as i said every Waxman
Waxman generated 24 expansions of
medicaid in the 1980s i mentioned last
time for an exhibit of inconstancy
there's not an exhibit but an instance
of end constancy alright there's a good
book by excellent book several by her
Martha terrific a book in 1990s she went
back she's the foremost writer on a
social security program back program bag
Mike tonight d going back to nineteen
thirty-five between nineteen thirty-five
and nineteen ninety she found in the
records 92 changes in a calculation of
Social Security benefits that's a lot
makes it hard to administer the program
but you know I there it now one way to
look at all this the messiness on
Capitol Hill is that it's so its
accuracy I mean it's a kaleidoscopic
ramshackle exercise of democracy as
people want this they want that they
want that and as they travel through
time somewhat this somewhat that
somewhat that done with that hey what
they want their they get all this the
way Congress it makes Congress the
natural enemy of those of us who are
rationalistic or fastidious as does its
in not surprising that Congress is
catnip for the media for the
Intelligencia in the college's it's as
anything else I think it's this
propensity to have messiness so i dub
violation of the cannons that doing
thing according to executable logic
that puts people off but it is it could
be said anyway to be a ramshackle
exercise of democracy and after all
people do want these things and then in
the 19th century before the people
wanted to land the veterans wanted the
pendants and so on the steel into one of
the tower if you know it's a kind of
additive additive way of going about
them as about delbarton bourdelle one of
Miss Brooks erode what if you look at
American American democracy empirically
look at what it amazes book preface and
democratic theory it's it's a story of
minorities rule minorities rule as
people who want something and go after
it maybe they'll get it it's a it tells
us in that book all right the last of
the last slide will be my home k yes but
as I say it causes identity despair does
this among the fastest and it seems to
have brought at least one major effect
where see this Quranic its aggressive
leading author on and it's that it's
been difficult to build this meant Rufus
it was surely late 19th century and
early a twentieth century than it is now
but it's still somewhat true I think so
difficult to build efficient
bureaucracies in the US federal
government efficient bureaucracy instead
of to say units that you look at and say
oh well there's an admirable
instantiation of instrumental
rationality this candle put into a
package and put into a building down
there now maybe I probably about it you
have to make an exception here for the
military I mean American military at
least some of the bureaucratese the
military are pretty pretty effective as
its of them anyway but generally
speaking the army righteous in the right
direction you don't agree with it but in
the domestic of arena it's been hard to
build them and many are they many are
the illuminating judgments on this I
found some good quotes you could wave a
story around these quotes but let's just
look at the quotes this is gerenuk the
first one he's writing about the late
19th century the late 19th century no
he's writing about the whole 19th
century American stayed here I think in
this passage the idea of opposing
imposing
without an abstract structure of
positions salaries job qualifications
and duties on the administrative branch
challenge the way Congress appropriated
funds a challenge is a committee thing
Ways and Means Committee in the house
was it to switch on that one a challenge
the prerogatives of Congressman to
intervene a departmental affairs there
it is that being the case dot dot dot
cuanto me too as the 20th century rolled
around this is set of scotch poland and
north or alive i found it i found the
first name what is the first name and
the legacies of patriot is democracy in
the conjunction of its crisis and they
progressively are created a much less
favorable context for advocates of
old-age pensions that is uh and what
she's looking at there they're looking
at there is a congressional think
dominantly actually is the difference of
emphasis that is a sketch ball hitter
writing emphasizes the parties as
location of this particular ism and
messiness whereas i really like this
Charles Francis Adams which very clearly
locates in Congress this is slightly
it's a different emphasis it's a
different at different distances and I
was writing my electrical connection
book back in 1973 which may be some of
you read I would have been delighted to
have had access to this work by Charles
ransom Adams it would have poured right
into my paragraphs there's no question
about it alright this third quote is so
is about the state legislature is rather
than about Congress and it's from a book
by Sean feel I think it's andrew is that
what Andrew shown feel night I really
love this book I read it when I was a
kid it's a minor capitalism i think it
was called and it's about capitalism and
less a political
political economy you know in some of
the big countries the u.s. France
Britain and some other places he looks
at the USA and finds the u.s. us to be
very liberal in a 19th century liberal
sense very differently constructed from
pressure with its bureaucracy at the
center or France with its bureaucracy at
the center of things and he says this
about the 19th century state
legislatures which I think probably
would apply to the US House a pretty
good degree the essential trouble was
that state legislatures tended to regard
the management of a public enterprise is
merely an extension of the of the
conventional political process it was
not so much that they were corrupt which
they were thought to be in the 19th
century after all as if they were
committed to an amateur's view of the
needs of management paging the vanishing
the school paging the School of
Management that was there the final
quote this is from Martha terrific in
that book Congress engages endlessly
lawmaking and it's soda and in doing so
it displays little independent and
little independent interest in
anticipating the administrative
consequences of its enactments period
what's pretty blunt statement and I mean
look I think all you're going with this
overboard I say maybe it's a too bad a
wrap that's being laid on Congress if
you take all these all these statement
in conjunction not that bad after all
they're not that bad nonetheless
nonetheless is a phone bouncing side
toward this kind of difficulty and the
placing of the US and the American
system probably probably probably it's a
yes so some consequences of this I would
think that this is a set of scotch balls
argument that and also well Jacob makes
a slightly different argument actually I
talked about Jacobs argument last time
about the revenue wax in 1942 in 1954
it's a discussion is that the u.s. came
to a federal welfare safe late and has
kept a small at least partly but its
reason that it was difficult to build a
French or Swedish or by then German are
the German or by that Swedish style
bureaucracy
they would administer it at the center
it was a tough sell to public opinion to
say let's build something big and let
these folks down there run it run it a
tough sell is that I would guess just to
finish it off that that another possible
of spin-off of this of the of the
rational messages is they apparently
gotten this speculation I don't know
buddy who wrote this is the accentuated
accentuated Lee privateness of the
American system of capitalism I mean at
the federal level is very little public
ownership in the USA you know when the
old liberalism came along Margaret
Thatcher had a lot of things that
private eyes but Reagan didn't a little
bit but not very much there hasn't been
that much public ownership I mean the
american way of dealing going back to
around 1900 has been to regulate
industries but don't try to own them or
run them that's regulate them don't try
to own them or run them and they're
Americans became pioneers and experts at
setting up regulatory instruments as the
American regulatory agencies really did
set the pattern for the world and some
of them pretty good but owning or
running industries production units or
units of communications or
transportation as well as manufacturing
they the US has not done much of I think
it's already it's always it's always
made sense to keep Congress a couple of
months likes away from from my units
that have to engage in a big way in
production and in so doing instantiate
instrumental rationality that is it's a
the mean the propensity is taught in
coherence and constancy in particular
isn't cannot and play it can can be a
danger it can be a matter of menace I
had to show this it's a speculation as
an inference is a little bit of evidence
that will bear it out there are thick
fennels writing about the Congressional
administered
the national administration of the post
office during the first six decades of
the 20th century look it's not bad the
post office is one of the world's great
organizations in some way I really do
get my meal every day which is stunning
in a sense yet it has troubles you know
it often has troubles and the the
particular troubles during the several
decades that fennel took a look at where
the Congress had his fingers in they
would at once they would they would they
would serve asleep a postal workers
unions and they would respond and very
populous take faster than what voters
wanted have any they would they cost of
postage stamps which made for money
difficulties and management of the
colonies in the post office over long
period of time is the kind of the mark I
got a kind of democracy in action once
they they I think the country the US
says so I looked into this and I
couldn't get very deep into it but it's
interesting question is interested
subject they the u.s. hasn't had except
for a reason you know am travel be
coming back on rail and all that or the
late nineteenth in the first half of the
20th century the US didn't own the
railroads I mean a lot of countries the
railroads have been routinely public
enterprises owned by governments and
conducted by governments the US has not
done that and even went something like
con really they've kept the you know a
kind of public corporation a
considerable distance from the
congressional committees and there was a
juncture when having federal ownership
and conducting of the railroads
railroads that might last for a long
time was a live option this was in 1919
this is after will well one during the
wore the government seized the railroads
for good reason or clogs and actually
during the war the government ran them
very well it did but after the war it
came down to the question of what are we
going to have for the long future here
we're going to have publicly on
railroads and privately owned railroads
the answer was we're going to have
privately owned
Rhodes if we if we make them publicly
owned that who knows what's going to
happen for one thing they as for the
post obviously the labor unions might
come in and more or less though reach
through Congress and and and motor and
motor them motor them or them I'm going
to stop with that okay Monica back Jacob
right speaks into the microphone and so
please yeah the micro gonna go through
the list of people who are acquitted
last slide and then got a point Mike
right out next year mouth as it turns
out kind of got to put the mic right I'm
not airing I'm going to have to
interlock you until the cute it's asking
about congressional legit yeah yes how
you think about that yeah yeah well I
mean I talked a little bit about that in
the first lecture and it's I mean a
couple points are that the if you mean
sorry about that sorry about that if you
would if you look at the job job rating
soon of Congress there's a you know
polls going back Eddie is it so almost
always there under the water a lot of
volatility and they're pretty low now
but I don't see a slope over the years
or so they just down there it probably
doesn't like the way Congress reforms
and they don't seem to like that there's
some studies of this because public
doesn't like to see conflict so they say
clean up in Iraq don't be so conflicted
that's point one point two though there
is other evidence out there and that if
you there's a good study by the
Annenberg folks I
did this last time I 2005 06 when the
Republicans man we're running all the
Congress and the presidency if you i
forgot my exact statistics but it was so
who should be breaking the laws should
Congress other president I mean Congress
is way ahead we're talking about five to
one it's not even close I've seen a pole
like that for four under Obama also main
who should be making the policies or the
laws Congress's way and it's really
quite surprised the way the public says
that to ask the public when they prefer
are they do they understand that it is
going to be conflicted they'll say yes
the asset whether it's a good idea to
have checks they say yes by it's not
even close so we want to say there's a
you know the family of questions which
could supply company of results I think
that and it's not going to be
dispositive and we really don't know i
would say another another room left
handed or inferential inference to reach
more might be this one that if you look
at I didn't say this last time but it
occur it's me right now if you look back
up with the hundred years 150 years at
reform efforts that's what if you take
the American institutions which ones are
really bad should we get rid of them I
think the the pink for such assertion
was had to do with the Senate the first
decade of the 20th century just before
they passed 17th amendment affecting the
Senators but since then I don't think as
a has been anything important out there
that they force and a force out there
an illegal act or eight late actor's toy
try to reach for anything else now maybe
the rather silly to reach for anything
else we're not going to have a bottom
entry system actually maybe change the
critical burns 101 but so it's so there
than there isn't any clear decisive
answer to it but I think that I think
also by the way that the it is important
to say that in so far as dating system
as legitimacy what the president's do is
just extremely important I mean a
presidential system can't get along
without presidents mean they're the
source of energy as Hamilton said they
should be and you know that so it's
really the compliments the comp I'm with
2 e's in it of the Congress in the
presidency I think that generates
whatever there is no way of legitimacy
20 website great oops I'll say here
thank you David early on you indicated
that you were going to dismiss the
institutional setup of Congress and I'm
wondering if an extension of your
argument is that this process would have
unfolded similarly under different
institutional arrangement or is it just
the fact that the changes to the
institutional changes over time of the
period that you look at the Congress
simply don't matter that we would have
seen this type of influence even under
different institutional arrangements
well I really don't know of course I
mean if you look at 1787 the system was
devised at that point nobody had seen
political parties nobody is in a big
country I think heterogeneous
tree under 11 under one flag with a
Republican arrangement Knoxville a
Republican arrangement a devising a
parliamentary system as the British one
later became would have been I don't
know how they could have done that I
think that so for the before the Civil
War let's put it that way before the
Civil War it's a very loose system and
it's called by David dooney estates yoga
rather than a state it's very low sort
of like the EU today sort of like the EU
today was the USA before the Civil War
and I think for the purposes of that the
Congress was was well atonement to
preserve a reasonable comedy across the
sections among whites across
intersections keeping the country from
sweating up for a long period of time
that's the point tool when the Civil
yeah okay just legislative that beyond
that I really don't know
and given that a couple of our biggest
entitlement programs Social Security
Medicaid Medicare okay put our blood
sorry the two of our most important
title in programs Medicaid Medicare job
security we're just with some bipartisan
support yep the latest big entitlement
program vertical Care Act passed with
Democratic majority not a single
Republican vote yeah key to the
president what do you think the fate is
of that what do I think what the fate is
of the Affordable Care Act cancer by oh
no I look like God I think it's ugh and
maybe maybe in that answer you can talk
about things that have been undone by
Congress after president has left office
or younger's has changed well I think
it's very risky to pass a big
complicated law within that design and
that coalitional design very very risky
because you just don't innovate as every
every incentive for the opposition party
who had nobody's appointing it try to
trash it downstream if it's not popular
and hasn't been that popular so it's
very risky very risky very risky
particularly to enact it at a
circumstance when the Republic opinion
was not especially supportive if public
opinion have been especially a
supportive there be another thing but it
wasn't so now what happens downstream I
think that I gotta feel repeal Obamacare
don't think so i think the the
likelihood on something like this it's
just continued mastication and amendment
and take this out and put that in and
diminish rent and a question and so
forth it's the way Congress operates
it's seldom do they actually reveal
something seldom they reveal something
and they could not repeal period
Obamacare because some of it some of
those components are popular like you
know for the kids up to age 25 there's
some components that are popular and it
looks like it's settling into to
something that has enrolled additional
three percent of the population
something like that so it might achieve
a place and the scheme of things
eventually this of the order of the
Supplemental Security income or their
income town
compared income tax credit but it's got
an earnest or in its own way into that
league so to speak those are programs
that started small EIT started small and
got pretty big Obamacare started at
least a principal big but we don't know
how big it go to is going to stay or how
I i we but you particularly if the
Republican state cook over everything in
January of two thousand and 2017 what
would they do I think that well actually
they might repeal it but if they repeal
them what they would do they sort of
committed to formally repealing it they
would they would pass along cited an
instrument there retains some of its
important components if they didn't then
they'd be real in real trouble with the
electorate so it could be a follower and
feel without its being a real repeal put
it that way something like that
third mari is a third mari us again i am
george responsible try it's talking
about third parties oh yes it was
getting into heart attacks I'm getting
ahead Harry that's all third parties
young I would think this is not a fair
question but if anybody makes sense of
my mumble and I think it would be you
I'm a registered Republican because I'm
looking to bring the party back to its
senses even though my friends hate me
because I bought it the other way and I
would think right now that Republican
House could be so paralyzed that maybe
it will have to split in two and that
will make the second and third party is
it German fans like that historically it
has caused the formation of a third
party well this a lot of hot water that
this living in and swimming around in
down and ahead and down there I it's
very difficult it's very difficult and
he will put it this way in the US it's
fairly easy to put on the boards a third
party that is just for an executive
office and you can run George Wallace I
can read and when they can run man Mayor
Bloomberg in New York you did when you
could do that one person who is well
known but to invent a third party that
goes all the way down to the ticket the
Senate the US House state legislators is
extremely difficult
but one reason is that we're going to is
that there are state laws that structure
what the dominating processes are for
part two get into politics and the laws
make it overwhelmingly desirable if
you're going to run for office to run at
a Republican primary or a Democratic
primary so it's very difficult to get
away from that very difficult so right
now i think that the what you say could
happen i doubt it i doubt if they'll
break up though I they could commit
suicide in a sense of they'll perform so
badly that they lose their majority in
the next election which is another
matter they might well do that it's a
big mess but I oh I guess I don't think
that they will break up that way that's
a likely we haven't had on a third party
that has made even made a dent in
congressional elections since then since
nineteen twelve and even that den was
pretty small it was a dent it just
doesn't happen i think so i think that's
the best best answer i think so thank
you i'll take the prerogative of the end
of the introducer so you ask a question
of my own which is somewhat related to
steve's an implication of the argument
it seems to me is that contemporary
gridlock if it's reflective of
polarization is is reflective basically
of where our democratic public is and by
which i mean small d Democratic
notwithstanding the low legitimacy
levels of the of the institution at
present and I guess I wonder how you how
you see the relationship I mean that
this is a fairly sunny view that
Congress it may be incoherent it may at
times uphold white supremacy but it's
basically performing its function of
representing those who vote and so but
there are obviously our strong arguments
to the effect that the public as a whole
is not nearly as polarized as
congressional eat so I'd wonder how you
would address that and you think that
the current lack of strong support for
Congress is partly reflective of a
disconnect between where representatives
are and where the public is I i think i
agree with that except on scholarship
this a new manuscript by theory in
making the case again that the public
out there is simply not it's polarized
as is the as are the elite classes elite
sectors of the political little clinical
public i mean are they to get George
Soros and you get and you know you get
the Koch brothers and again talk show
radio and so on which is a leap so when
they're you get polarization just Tom
Steyer the guy who flies the plane with
streamers coming down all that yes yes
now they and but it's not just a few
people I mean it's probably hundreds of
thousands of people maybe millions of
people who are the activists course of
the parties now who are pretty
ideologically committed
sighs and we'll push their parties to
the left and to the right I think that's
true so in that circumstance what
happens well I think that it makes it
difficult on Capitol Hill and we can see
the difficulty that it that it generates
you know I think that maybe I think I
think that obey let me make a couple of
answers one is that they the despite
they ugly optics of the process is down
there the shutdowns and so forth all
that they the resultant of the policy is
but maybe just about where the median
voter is on some of these things
probably like taxing and spending I mean
the public is divided on taxing and
spending public is divided on sites of
the fist size of the size of the the
federal budget as a proportion of GDP us
just is one of those things it's fairly
pretty evenly matched on the
bread-and-butter issues of American
politics out there out there in the
public and so either in that
circumstance either either gridlock or
doing nothing there's a Serb a balance
of settled policy or making greasy
bad-looking Gables feels like the budget
deals in recent times is responsive to
the median voter all that now that have
you had I think that's out there now
they-they-they i think that there's some
there are some matters that we're we're
expertise could should way into our
thinking about politics and on some
matters that sometimes anyway we
probably would agree that expertise
should prevail rather than the views of
the median voter and that might be true
on our
take for example and that is of
arithmetic immediate vote it might be a
little shaky arithmetic but over a long
period of time the Fisk has got to be in
pretty good day shape and arithmetic Lee
so it's a or on science matters of
science the median voter maybe maybe
asked off science I Madison process and
its political science it's a pretty
going on process expertise so I've known
as a work expertise it seems to me is a
pretty clearly prevail candidate forum
for for supremacy why then or
particularly we are particularly
entitled to say that the system is
growing up and it's not doing what what
what auto by these statuses of expertise
ought to be done so I think a lot of
commentary is that that's dealing on the
debt deficit dealing on climate change
are instances after all up / vailable
expertise at least you know reasonably
plausible expertise I think that on for
most of the residual above at least
domestic policy forget about foreign
policy for the moment there is a it's
not so easy to say that anybody's
expertise to prevail that is there ought
to be democracy somewhere and going to
be up there I most policy issues in most
times that is it most times in most
matters what happens in policy is ought
to be plausibly the resultant of tastes
vectoring a dead and to Congress if
tastes can do that so now I think of now
they I think probably now they I think
in the last decade or let 15 to 20 years
or so there are just not out there in
the public majorities there's not a
liberal majority and there's not a
conservative
already that's rather kind of a muddle
or kind of a balance and this excerpt is
blank as i get what they want and the
Liberals complained because they can't
get what they want at least often and
it's not surprising but it's very well
that they shouldn't in either case if
there isn't if there is it from a
standpoint of representation it's like
you know there it is quite plausible
vision thanks David I think we can all
appreciate you on the ground expertise
as well as on the grounds of the
Democratic public consept thanks very
much